I'm looking if it was working and a lot
of people have something that I'm pretty
sure is right it's just got not what
you're supposed to be get it right
something done anything incorrect it's
more that you don't know where you're
going I think what I sort of um compare
what a lot of your son is like you drive
it right and I said you hey can you get
me for okay to be right and you said
cool I can drive you get on the road you
start to look at the birth time you know
like an internet search all people i'm
following the law but then you end up
like in the wrong state you're like but
i didn't do anything wrong but that's
true you didn't do anything wrong you
just we're taking me anywhere you were
going you're just following what you
normally ran over dude which i take it
simplify careful things up and prepare
to nostalgia the first thing I need to
say is what I mentioned before you
started which is that this is a first
question and it's all three questions
this must be the line you conclude with
it cannot be the line son you can't just
read that and then say equals and then
started into fighting now let me prove
if you start with anything proof of
battery okay if I let myself start with
that is the first line I can do some
mathematically correct thing and then
come up with true statement so if this
is true does this mean this is true
nature is don't see at all with
mathematical notation okay that first
line is wrong to begin with you can't
start with that because it's hot right
now this is not fun we should just know
whether it is or not that's kinda point
okay you can't start there
anything which is why my son finally
left hand side equals now I will point
out eternus stopping let their size you
can start with right hand side and
during your waking life but generally I
might look better going from messier
thing to me two things right now it
turns out with these are somewhat messy
but this is pure objectivity one so I'm
better at taking two objects and
combining them that I am at taking one
object and splitting apart that's
another big week okay we've done
hundreds of questions like as these two
actions right when did you ever do a
question which is my pain with a top
distraction no one's got that still
developed and practice so take advantage
of what you worried that I'm going to
look at eleven okay now before I start
your lease up with the left hand side I
actually do for my own sake what to know
where I'm headed right just like if you
were going from A to B you've got to
have a rough idea of the direction
you're headed so over here on the right
hand side of spawn I'm going to work out
what the right hand side is supposed to
be it's not by working out that is my
solution if me try to Macedonia in my
brain ok so if I just look at em co
efficient ok this is going to be a
fraction what will the top of us
right here it's not what I program on
the door they only have 2 factorial the
first one is going to be the whole
cetera and then the other one is going
to be remember see how that is this heck
I did you see that so there 48 I am
going to do this take my do yeah you
with me you see how this plus one or
both of them see they're going to cancel
each other yeah so that will leave me
with this okay you'll really so far okay
so i am doing that with the purpose of
like i'm basically sitting okay excuse
my destination in google map so now I
know where I'm going now I can actually
start the judges here we go NCR NP plus
1 you just go straight to your
definition there's the first binomial
coefficient is an excellent
again I'm not quite finished with
distraction be careful there's negatives
flying around and you want to make sure
that you're subtracting exactly the
right thing it's going to be this number
the top one takeaway is a whole bottom
number right once you subtract r plus 1
then it's minus r minus 1 you represent
what r perform in brackets yeah so
therefore this is n minus R minus 1
factorial tasting so far I've already
done a substantial amount mental work to
get to this point okay if result the
first line of memory so far so good now
I just as we've just demonstrated to
pretty great combining fractions into
one passion so TR we have a problem
which is that leads to has different
about it right so cool okay so I need to
get them the same but he is why we're
going on right in touch board he's lying
set my journey from the beginning if I
said to you this question I said he has
important you would automatically work
out what the development it should made
what issue right you tender denominators
should be 21 because that's the lowest
one you can get and then you would
personally convert then you too much ok
gr I could put that question to you as
well that would turn two fractions into
one but you don't mean to answer that
question because the question itself
already told you what they do know that
it should be there it is right there
okay now maybe there is a system
I don't think there is but doesn't
matter this is the one you're supposed
to go to so you might as well get
everything in that glory does that make
sense you see how one idea and what I
we're going where I'm going when we do
trig identity crucial in return it's
going to be exactly the same you've got
to know the destination okay 17 time
look at this what do i need to multiply
this by so it has this denominator look
something will rematch today what will
ready management the inverted r
factorial is already in place that's
good ok I've got our factorial but I'm
supposed to have a plus one that's worse
and she probably like a [ __ ] we're
going to turn this guy into this guy
right so what would you like me to x
the file if I had digital box and it is
x proprietary to this number you
multiply it by six sweetie oh great well
that's what you're dealing with here
this is your sink that's world mitch is
fine the more to multiply the top and
bottom of that fraction by r plus 1 you
Whitney so fun okay let's do it no color
and pictorial on the top added our class
1 and / ok now it's not a factorial
anymore is it is now I'll plus 1
factorial I'm just go like that i'm
looking to second fraction see ok so
don't need i want to turn into this just
like before with the first fraction part
of it already looks good domina which
one the utmost 1 factorial is exactly
what i wanted to be there and they're so
justice other thing that's missing even
amid to work with this guy and this guy
the hortators this relationship here you
see how this is one left to live yeah
isn't that exactly what we were dealing
with over here so this is one less than
what it's supposed to be so all you need
to do it should multiply by the next sub
roll ok ultimate dinner I in fact you're
already on top I already have the r plus
1 factorial that I want to turn this
into n minus R factorial the earthly
terms museum is the n minus R I already
have all the terms after it so a little
x hunter
sorry that was a little beard algebra
and there isn't even one happy but we
got their colors denominator not
learning the a common denominator we had
the common denominator what we're
supposed to get right so i can say
that's what's on the bottom and perfect
don't touch it just simplify a lot of
people you start putting the other
you're like cool like it's not canceling
stuffed up that might be right put it
work in your way to swim you don't want
to cancel that let's stay exactly where
it is all right robear look at the top
combined into d rated so he is one of
them and he is the unlock coming back to
us life namely and factorial if you
bring that out the front what do you get
left with for the rest of it is all but
one of them there and then then n minus
R of them is is there you're great
sitting up Rebecca better on the
denominator if you don't want a
statistic okay but look look what
happens with what happened r minus r so
they go on the oil left on that
numerator is n factorial times n plus 1
through what happens when you multiply
by the next up roll oh I erna thought
you tied into the next set Oriole okay
which is Courtney it is n plus 1
factorial
and lo and behold you just cruise with
driving or not yes my concern was one
you should prove castles identity
remember Haskell's identity you add one
time in the next one that makes you go
down a road and do that